okay this is a tutorial video for the
puddles in pepper panic saga
you can see here they're
little puddles of water that sit on
certain tiles um they don't move they
stay in the same place
and
they were released in level 416 with a
double release of the two episodes at
the same time
now if you're familiar with the grills
that came out a little while ago then um
the easiest way to understand how these
works work is that they're exactly the
opposite
the grills the you know
on the grills levels whenever you have a
pepper over
hot coals it grows faster
shock waves make it grow faster when
it's sitting on top there and um
you know when you match them together
over that they'll grow faster as well on
this with puddles it's exactly the
opposite
so make a match
with two that are outside of it
and
one that's on the puddle and it grows
one
but whenever
you get it a little bit bigger
or use three that are all on the puddles
it doesn't grow at all
so
we got three one reds um
and it just stays a one because it was
matched over top of the puddle
same thing here we have a shock wave
that's going to go down
normally this would grow these
both but
you can see they stay exactly the same
size
and here we have a four one
two three
that would that would normally be
a match that would make an explosion
but when we make it over the puddle
instead it makes it um
just grow to a stage five instead of
exploding
so
they're really just there to get in the
way um as you can see there you can
explode peppers on top of them if it's a
large enough number
but um
you know they just like the um grills
accelerate things they slow things down
so here we have two ones
plus the stage five
and we get no explosion
and
you can see when we move it off off of
there it explodes here we have a 201 and
a 5
and that's the extra that has the extra
dots that you need to make it explode
same here this one didn't explode when
we matched it with two ones but now
we're going to match it with a bunch
and it will explode
so
i'm trying to think of a level that'll
show this a little bit i'm going to go
ahead and quit this one and go on to one
of the higher levels
let me try i think some people were
asking in the group about level 444 this
morning and i don't remember this one
off the top of my head but i'm thinking
it probably has bubbles
okay yeah now we got a lot of puddles
and we need to make
patterns which um
this really actually won't be affected
by
the puddles much at all but we can still
talk about and you know see where they
fall into place
we also got mr claus here
which you know he's really not as big of
a factor when it comes to the puddles
levels because you don't have that many
grown peppers for on the steel
and in this one um you know since we
don't actually i'm not going to play
this level because it's going to um
this is a lot harder of a concept to
understand when you have to make panics
so i'm not going to play the
match pattern one
see another one people were asking about
was 338
i wish i knew what all these ones were
at the same time
all right yeah this one's a little bit
better of an example
this is a statues level not a panic's
level but
what makes this one hard is you've got
all of these
huddles on the outside and
mister claws and you have to try to get
explosions going on in the middle so
ideally you're going to want to try to
make match fives
and you can see we have a match four
here that's not going to do a whole
whole lot so i was just trying to see if
i could turn that into a match five
this is also interesting because you can
see the difference between the grilles
and the puddles side by side
this is completely blocked up here so
i'm just going to go ahead and make this
match
but just kind of pay attention to the
numbers i'm not going to count them all
out
but um just pay attention to how the
numbers change
like here we have a one two and a one
that's partially over
a grill
so if we go up that way it grows
normally
because we didn't have any puddles
involved
and the same thing there was over the
grill so it grew
but like here we have a four one and a
one and we match that over the puddle
and it just stays a four it doesn't grow
at all
so on this level you know you want to
get some on the grills down here because
if you can fire a shockwave down it'll
explode them and mr claus is all the way
up here so let's try to do that now
before he comes down
everything's kind of blocked in front of
that one
not a real good setup here
i'm just trying to cycle things downward
to see if something will set up above
okay i kind of played that fast but you
could see that that purple one was
sitting on the um grill and it exploded
but nothing
that was sitting on the puddles below
did anything we'll do that again here's
a shock wave right
we got a green one that's a stage three
right now on the grill and then we got
two stage ones below it on the puddles
and you see that green one grew two
stages
instead of just growing one it what
became a stage five and the two stage
one stayed exactly the same
so really that's all there is to it um
these things get in the way like i said
if you can
work around them as much as possible
here's another one um
you know we got a stage three and two
stage ones
even though it was on the grill when it
started
it didn't grow at all since it ended up
on the puddle
so if you have any questions about these
just ask and
i'm going to be writing the guide
for both the
coals
grills and the um
puddles where we describe them side by
side and that'll give you a little bit
more insight so
let me know if you have any questions
like the video if you found it helpful
and
we'll make a new video soon